I've got a great documentary
recommendation for you today it's called
the ivory game it's a netflix original
it is very very depressing and the film
goes to three different countries this
was actually executive produced by
leonardo dicaprio and it exposes the
very horrifying underground world of
ivory trafficking this includes the
poaching of elephants in Africa this
also includes fundraising in the UK to
try to stop poaching and it includes
both um sort of on the record and
undercover footage in Hong Kong and
China which is one of the major ivory
markets that remains in the world it
really is horrible and I think it's
super important to know that this is
going on uh but it's really really
depressing and what what's going on
these elephants being killed just for
their tusks elephants having armed
guards because they are such targets for
poachers I'm guessing uh Pat since
you're vegan you're also anti ivory
right I don't think there's many vegans
who are pro ivories that yes that's the
correct assessment I have have you seen
Rachel how these ivory tusks that's just
insane prices and people consider it in
some parts of the world although in the
u.s. it's increasingly going out of
style because I think there's a closer
understanding of of how it is that we
get ivory but Hong Kong and China to the
major markets people just love this
stuff they displayed in their home I
would be ashamed to display ivory in my
home because of what it represents and
the violence it represents I think the
education is causing the the positive
shift because it's historically seen as
something that is such a status symbol
yeah but I feel like as people get more
educated they want to shift further away
from it I completely agree with that and
it's horrifying when you see the ways
also china for example pass laws at a
certain point which said you can't bring
in new ivory you can't bring in any new
ivory the ivory you have you can sell
but you can't bring in new ivory and the
ivory dealers have figured out a way to
completely circumvent this because they
just retag new ivory
as old ivory and then sell the old stuff
I me that there's it's you it's not a
foolproof method by any means and the
undercover footage that they show here
being taken to these back rooms and
asking how are how am I gonna get the
ivory back to my country when its
international buyers that go to China
and the ivory dealers say we deal with
this all the time we're going to help
you it's absolutely horrifying what's
amazing now too is a lot of elephants
are being born without tests yes that's
the evolutionary advantage they won't be
the target of hunters we did that story
on the bonus show and and by the way at
one thing I did not mention when we did
that story about as a result of poaching
elephants being increasingly born with
and never developing tasks that's also
evidence of Darwinian evolution which I
know will upset many of the religious
rightists that watch the show which uh
they they they are numerous uh but yeah
and the way it works is if the elephants
with the nicest tusks are most
attractive to poachers it's more likely
that they will be killed before they
have the opportunity to reproduce
meaning elephants with a subpar or sub
optimal tusks live longer and it sort of
creates this gene pool of elephants with
worse and worse tusks living long enough
to reproduce and it eventually starts
leading to as we're seeing now some
elephants born without tests so
absolutely horrifying but very much
worth knowing about I am talking about
the netflix original documentary the
ivory game you can check out this and
all of my other recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations and of
course the indy gogo fundraiser is on at
david pakman.com slash donate we'll take
some calls next